I will beat you like a Cherokee drum
[Music]
took longer than I expected
if you're gonna catch dawn you guys are
gonna work together surprise I just fell
in love I've been waiting for this we
got a tank let's roll
[Applause]
I don't know if the old Dom is in there
I don't give a damn I'm taking you down
so right oh let's play
why are they shooting at me I don't know
maybe cuz you're always laughing
[Music]
we are about to go
see we're gonna need a bigger truck
[Music]
don't you're gonna turn your back on
family
[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie so let's just
watch the rock beat everybody like a
Cherokee drum in like it seems like the
villains and the heroes have all
switched sides
so Jason Statham is on the team this
time just because this is so crazy and
there's so many more trailers dropping
in the next couple weeks I'll go ahead
and just start a giveaway so all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be
sure to click that Bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss anything there's
supposed to be justice Lee coming soon
so you can see what the action of this
movie is it's dumb vs. the family like
you just shake your fist in the air how
dare you turn on the family Fast &
Furious movies are all about the family
they really stop being about the cars
after they rebooted the franchise with
the fourth film and I still feel like
the fifth one is probably the best so
far obviously we haven't seen this one
yet but the thing that I'm most excited
about as crazy as this looks is just
this crazy Grand Theft Auto movie is
that they have Charlize Theron and they
have Helen Mirren there isn't a whole
lot of her in the trailer but Vin Diesel
said that people hounded him so much his
fans on Facebook were just like you have
to work with Helen Mirren so he reached
out to her and she was totally down to
play with them like she's been in movies
like red so she's played like the badass
old lady character before we don't
really know much about her in the film
but you're not really allowed to be in a
fast and furious movie if you don't
break something or rekha car or just
beat the crap out of somebody so
whatever it is they have her doing it's
gonna be a lot of fun
like even Kurt Russell gets to have a
lot of fun even though he has a
relatively passive role he's like the
enabler you need new cards here you go
like he just unleashes all these crazy
new vehicles so they kind of tease the
big action set-pieces one of them is the
big ice battle with them on the frozen
lake with the submarine we're gonna need
a bigger car nice jaws reference I'm
guessing that's probably Charlize Theron
inside that submarine but if you're not
really familiar with the twists and
turns of a fast and furious movie really
like DOM is all about family that's the
most important thing to him so the only
thing that would cause him to turn on
his family is if the villain Charlize
Theron forced him to do it she's this
crazy next-level hacker she probably
forces him to help her or else the rest
of them are dead otherwise you wouldn't
be able to cut the trailer this way but
you can see how they're just
trying to hype everybody up like oh my
god the family's broken up like that's
the thing on the poster here family no
more so earlier this year the funniest
thing happened the rock totally called
out someone on his fast and furious cast
for being a candy-ass like he was going
after them hardcore did not say who it
was but everyone was like he's probably
talking about Vin Diesel who knows what
the drama was about so now it sounds
like we know what was going on because
in real life the rock is the nicest most
professional person you could possibly
imagine so he'd never call some went out
publicly like that using his social
media but then you see like the first 30
seconds of this trailer with them
finishing the job and him just driving
Hobbs off the road like he's betraying
the team and you're like oh okay that's
probably what this was all about they're
just trying to hype up the group being
at odds with DOM and if that wasn't
clear it's Dom working with the villain
who is Charlize Theron the rest of the
family has absolutely no idea what's
going on so they have to take him down
with the help of Kurt Russell who's kind
of like the government man with the
money that's where they get all the
money for the cars for so even though
it's totally nuts I love fast and
furious movies because they've been able
to transcend the cars onra like it's
kind of a Grand Theft Auto movie so even
though there's a lot of car racing a lot
of car action it's not about the cars
it's all about the family and I think
that was the smartest thing they did
when they brought it back with that
fourth film but here's a
behind-the-scenes featurette making of
that they release recently so check it
out is pretty crazy
I live my life a quarter mile at a time
nothing else matters
for those 10 seconds or less
[Music]
the open road could take you anywhere to
friends to family we know he's an
O'Conner but he's also a Tyrell
Jamal aboard venture let's do it to see
something new
what do you mean dream just to come back
home again
the facet of here is saga has explored
the endless possibility of the open road
from the streets just outside downtown
Los Angeles we've taken you to Miami
we've taken you to Tokyo the Dominican
Republic Rio London Abu Dhabi and now
our name is known all over the world we
have raced for speed race for honor -
Don was had you greens or cities tumbled
down mountains and even dropped out of
the sky but no matter how our adventures
grow fast and furious is always about
one very important thing
family the most important thing in life
will always be the people in this room
salute me from here our family of
characters do everything for each other
and with each other
for the millions who make up our global
family advance we push ourselves to go
further and do better time after time
we never ride alone we never ride alone
this time it ain't just about being fast
now we embark on our next chapter our
family will be challenged like never
before by adversaries who show no mercy
testing that farm that has always kept
us together
ambitious most entertaining fastest and
most furious ride yeah
is fast and furious so you can see they
feature a lot of Paul Walker and there a
lot of the franchise's dedicated to him
now so they found an interesting way of
working his brother into the film so
just look out for a lot of nods to Brian
gone but not forgotten but let me know
which is your favorite Fast & Furious
movie and if you could have any of these
cards which one would you pick you know
a lot of them are actually pretty
attainable like they're not super
expensive they're just tuned versions of
relatively affordable muscle cars but
you get into some of those military
vehicles like Hobbs ice RAM or the
brand-new Lambo yeah you're spending
almost like a half a million dollars so
what's gonna happen next is I'll post my
Walking Dead finale video that should be
up later tonight or at least early by
tomorrow morning so it's gonna be a
crazy week hopefully you guys have
started your holiday vacation but I'll
post updates on Twitter and Facebook on
when everything's posting what you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for the spider-man homecoming trailer
and you can click here for my Game of
Thrones Season 7 theory thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
we are about to go on life
[Music]